hi my name is jessie mostapak and i'm a
developer advocate here at rstudio and
today i want to take you on a quick high
level tour of rstudio cloud from the
perspective of an educator
[Music]
when you're getting ready to teach r
with r studio you have two main options
one option is to walk learners through
downloading and installing both r and r
studio on their local machine after
which you then have to walk through the
installation of all the necessary
packages as well as loading the packages
and if you're using git you've got to
install git and more often than not this
process results in spending a
significant amount of time
troubleshooting unique installation
issues across a variety of operating
systems
another option is to use rstudio cloud
rstudio cloud is a lightweight
cloud-based solution that allows you to
teach data science using the rstudio ide
directly from your browser with rstudio
cloud gitworks out of the box and you
can avoid the majority of the
installation issues you're likely to
encounter when you have learners
download to their personal computer
what's more you don't need any system
administration experience or it support
to get your course set up let's take a
look
once you log into rstudio cloud you have
a variety of tools available to you
in the menu on the left we can take a
look at workspaces you'll always have
your own personal workspace and you can
create additional workspaces for each of
your courses like this
[Music]
to avoid having students each download
packages to their computer we can set up
all of the projects within our workspace
using a default set of files and
packages by creating a base project this
means we can install all of the packages
used throughout our course along with
any files we want our learners to have
access to by default and we can update
this base project throughout our course
as needed
[Music]
let's check out what's available to us
within a workspace one of the first
things we can do is add members to our
workspace and set their default
permissions either through invitations
or by using a link
in addition to adding learners this is a
fantastic way to get any co-teachers and
teaching assistants added to your
workspace so that they can assist with
adding learners and setting up the
workspace
we can also create a new rstudio project
with the click of a button which will
take us to an r project that looks like
what we'd see in the desktop version of
the rstudio ide
from here we can share the project with
our learners and even convert it into an
assignment when we create an assignment
as educators our studio cloud
automatically makes a copy for our
learners and flags the project with the
assignment tag from our perspective
while showing learners either a start or
continue button for each assignment in
their workspace
another feature in rstudio cloud is the
ability for educators to look at a
learner's assignment this means that we
can run a learner's work on rstudio
cloud and better help them to identify
and debug any errors
while this doesn't cover everything you
can do with rstudiocloud i do hope it
inspires you to check out the
possibilities at
rstudio.cloud and if you'd like to learn
more please join us for an rstudio cloud
webinar at 1pm eastern on august 18 2021
right here on our youtube channel
we'll be showing you a pre-recorded
video from one of our resident cloud
experts and as the video plays our
studio staff will be available in chat
to answer all of your questions i can't
wait to see you there
[Music]
you